I have a follow-up question do you think
it's better to be a man or a woman in
2022.
it will always be your mom get me sorry
Clementine Ford Clementine Ford I have a
question my favorite hair box no I don't
know how to fold she's from I think
she's New Zealand or Australian the best
books you'll ever read in your life
amazing read her books and you'll
realize how men can be and how
we have been putting this pedestal off
oh yeah oh don't you guys don't you guys
don't you think that's a little bit
offensive like like no no can I get like
like because I like he could come out
and say well women are women are
trash and what it like like I just don't
know why